so I want to start with a statistic so
the weighted average of all job postings
on The Chronicle of Higher Ed inside yes
Chronicle of Higher Ed inside higher ed
and academic jobs wiki the weighted
average of all jobs that ask for some
degree of online teaching proficiency in
top positions they don't want anyone who
hasn't heard this statistic from me yet
and we want to guess everyone's heard
the statistic from me excellent right
it's forty nine percent which means
basically half of all jobs today are
asked in tenure track positions are
asking for some degree of proficiency
with online teaching if we just look at
academic jobs wiki which tends to gear
towards sort of junior faculty positions
or people who know how to use a wiki
there the number goes up to sixty
percent so a huge number of current jobs
today are asking for people who are
trained or at least have thought
seriously about online teaching and
learning now this is a challenge but
also an opportunity because if Yale
prides itself on on taking the best of
the best in graduate school and trading
them to become competitive on the job
market and that job market presumably
includes academia then we need to think
about how do we trained graduate
students to teach online now this is a
separate conversation from the what is
going on at Yale should classes at Yale
merge towards online or not they are
they're separate but related because
regardless of what we end up deciding to
do here at Yale there still is a
responsibility to Train graduate
students who most of most of whom will
not get there first their first job here
at Yale to train them to get competitive
jobs elsewhere now these jobs are deeply
interrelated as your question pointed to
because part of the way we trained
graduate students is by giving them
experience here at Yale but I do think
we need to make sure that we think about
these things as interrelated but still
somewhat separate so what have we been
doing to train graduate students I'm in
the Department of Religious Studies but
I'm also fellow at the Yale teaching
center
and last year they yelled teaching
center ran its first series of workshops
on how to teach an online course which
was essentially a learning experience
for me as its co-leader because I had no
idea how to teach into the mind course
and we came up together with a with a
list of best practices sort of how to
approach a job committee that asks you
would you be willing to teach an online
course with a series of questions that
you could ask and maybe some some things
you could drop so you sounds like you
know somewhat what you're talking about
and but but also we took we spent some
time looking at online classes sort of
we we dabbled in a bunch of the
different models and sort of talked
about what worked and what didn't and
what essentially came out of that is
that good teaching and learning are good
teaching and learning whatever platform
we use but that the platform can at
times detract from that and this came up
particularly because i think this
generation of graduate students grew up
with technology and is used to sort of
clean functional interfaces and it
became very much a barrier if if the
tech wasn't up to that standard so we
need to think about making sure that
great teaching and learning are at the
heart of something that can be processed
by its students the second thing that
we're doing right now is we're in we're
in communication with the broadcast and
media center to and hopefully we're
going to move on this this week to allow
to create a platform for graduate
students who want to create sort of five
minute online teaching demo reels some
jobs are now asking for you to have this
or at least asking if you have it can
they see it which of course means you
should have it and so we're going to
figure out ways to allow graduate
students to create these and mentor them
through creating sort of strong examples
of this and then finally you know we
when we talk about online teaching Yale
was not was not first to the first to
the plate and the same is true in
training graduate students so there are
other universities right now that have
much more robust programs in training
graduate students to do this in a
variety of ways but again as
the online teaching and learning is not
necessarily a bad thing the L was not
1st to the plate because that means we
have these great models that we can look
at so for example Duke University has an
online a practice apprenticeship which
comes with a semester-long course on
best practices in online pedagogy which
focuses both on sort of the various
platforms that one uses and also on
pedagogy which is fantastic and that is
paired with an apprenticeship with
somebody who is currently creating an
online class and that's a year-long
program that duke runs it's actually
quite competitive and people apply to
get in I think it comes with a little
extra cash but so that's one model
University of Wisconsin sort of on the
other end has a series of online
education programming for graduate
students which is entirely online so you
can watch these videos or written role
in online courses and have online
discussions I guess they're practicing
what they preach and so there are a
variety of ways that we can do this but
we do need to start thinking so
seriously about how we're going to
create that culture here and the GSA the
Graduate Student Assembly and the Yale
teaching center are two places where we
are beginning to have those
conversations but I think they need to
be more robust and hopefully they will
be as the time goes on I want to end
with sort of a broader systemic issue
and I think this I don't know whether
this is what you were going to ask me
but this does very much relate to nelec
as presentation and that is so we've
been talking about well I've been
talking about graduate students and
those are people who have already been
accepted and are hoping one day to get
an academic job early as many of them
are hoping to get an academic job and I
think one thing that we need to think
about as we move towards in many ways
these great neck networked experiences
how does that affect future hiring
because if the Northeast only needs one
teacher of Romanian do we have a
responsibility to accept fewer students
into the Romanian ph.d program I don't
actually Romanian was an example I have
no idea there is one but more broadly
this actually is an issue among my
friends who are coming up into the
I'm market who are having trouble
getting jobs in some of these rare field
because professors are saying well we
don't need somebody anymore because now
we have a joint program with University
of Virginia or Colonel or whoever and so
there is a real I think we really need
to stop and think about how many
students we accept into these PhD
programs if there won't be jobs for them
because funding people who I mean it's
in it the numbers don't lie in this
example and so we do i think really need
to think about that seriously and I I
just want to end by saying that in all
of this I think what's most important
the strongest candidates on the job
market when it comes to online teaching
and learning are those who've had
experience and so we need to figure out
ways to create to give graduate students
that experience and the summer school is
a great first start the new courses that
are being offered have graduate students
who are who are assisting in those as
courses multiplied so we'll
opportunities for graduate students but
it's also a very steep learning curve in
in learning how to do an online course
and I know there is a tendency to say
well this this person spent a year
learning how to do that so I'm just
going to have them be my TF for the next
three years which which will be easier
both for the student and the professor
but I think in terms of what's best for
graduate students as a whole it's
important that we make sure that those
experiences get spread out and and all
of the things that I've suggest now she
suggests an hour sort of top-down models
all right things that the university as
a whole can do or various institutions
at the university can do to support
online teaching and learning as they
apply to graduate students I know next
we're going to hear a bottom-up approach
and hopefully when we combine the two
will have some really some really rich
opportunities for graduate students okay
questions I can't actually see because
of the blinding light but oh yes hi I
have sort of a question or maybe even a
suggestion first of all I'm very happy
this question has been reason that
people need to be trained to teach
online not only graduate students but
also our faculty that are just jumping
into that
at Yale and elsewhere and I just wanted
as a suggestion you were mentioning some
strategies how we can train as students
and faculty and my belief is and I used
to run the program on certification
program for faculty at another
institution where I work and what what I
did I put them in the position of a
student online I think that's the best
way to learn because I don't think you
can really teach unless you've been a
student online so it was an eight-way it
could be any number of weeks online
program that has no face to face
interaction and that program teaches you
step-by-step how to create a course how
to design it best on practices that are
suggested and as a facilitator of that
program I used to put negative things in
so that the students get frustrated my
faculty got frustrated and from that
frustration they learned a whole a lot
about what not to do because first I
began as what to do that was way too
easy and they still made mistakes
afterwards so I switched and I began
making problems for them so that's just
as a suggestion that be happy to work
with creation center and get that off
the ground if you decide to go that
direction thank you and that's actually
the the model University of Wisconsin
uses that's why they do it all online
and one of the great advantages of the
graduate teaching center at Yale which
has recently been promoted to the Yale
teaching center now works with both
faculty and students which is a real
advantage in things like this please as
we figure out what works we can apply it
to both populations and I'd love to talk
to you afterwards about this specific
example anything else alright
you